all right now this idea here helps us to
geometrically understand what's going on
and what's all the arithmetic that's
happening and I sort of tease that at
the end of last lesson okay so what I
want you to do underneath this set of
axes is on Jordan you write a new
subheading for me which is vector
operations okay so let's do the ones
that you already know and then I'll show
you how the insights that we can gain
from this are really really powerful
okay
all right so firstly addition so draw
for me any pair of random vectors if you
like you can draw your vectors looking a
lot like mine so I've got a vector keep
going off in some direction like that
this uh arrow over the top of something
is the thing that indicates to you it's
a vector I'm going to call this vector P
and now let's draw another vector along
with it so something maybe like this
okay so each of these vectors has a
magnitude has a direction
what happens if I add these two things
together
well the vector P plus Q we saw this
before right this is the last thing
that's not be finished with last is last
week is basically the effect of doing
one vector after the other right it's
sort of like stringing them together in
a series okay so for example one way we
could get P plus Q is to do pay first
it's stored like that
and then do cute after that so looks
like this
okay so the new vector P plus Q is a new
vector that achieves the translation of
both of these factors combined right so
now this vector here that is P plus Q
okay so P plus Q achieves P and Q in
sequence okay now just like addition of
our regular numbers addition of vectors
is probably 10 do you remember we
mentioned this before so maybe I don't
want to do P first maybe want to do cube
first it's got to look like this I'm
gonna go do that downward to the right
translation and then afterwards I do
this one in the end if you can see of
course the net effect is the same and
that's because you can add vectors in
any order you like you still get the
same sum so far so good okay so that's
our rectangular form is what we use to
crunch the numbers on this and show that
it was the case of subtraction
how many subtraction how would you think
of subtraction okay so usually when we
think about like say five take away
three we're so good at doing subtraction
of real numbers that we just say oh the
difference between them and we just give
the answer okay but in terms of vectors
the direction is a little more valuable
and flexible so it's going to be more
helpful to think of it as the addition
of a negative vector okay so if I use
the same P and the same cube right and I
wanted to have say if we take away how
am I going to do this right here
unlike an addition the order matters so
I'm gonna do P first for reasons that
will become clear that our buddy
way over there now what would negative q
because that's really what about you
what would negative cute look like how
would you describe it yeah okay
your twin it is what here okay let's
find out so I've done this guy right
I've done the first part of this now I'm
gonna add on to I'm gonna stream on to
it negative cube and here's what Q looks
like right now negative Q has the same
magnitude just like say 2 and negative 2
have the same magnitude but they're
facing in opposite directions okay
another way of saying is it's been
rotated 180 degrees or PI radians okay
so I want you to think about this and
draw the same one I'll do it donning the
same vector same length but facing the
opposite direction like that now this
this guy here
this is negative here so I've done this
vector it's actually even a little bit
longer it's getting progressively
shorter as I keep going
there's the original vector P and now
I'm going to add on to it this guy
there's negative q so we're in this
diagram is paid to minus q its what yeah
it's what joins these two together it's
like this it's that guy then P take away
cute all right now one of the nice
things about this is it looks a bit like
everything's kind of adrift I don't have
any arm any coordinate actives or
anything like that to ground what's
going on here but you can connect these
two ideas it's very important that you
connect in this way the P plus Q and P
minus Q are kind of like these sides on
a triangle that I'll read later okay
here's how I'm gonna help you understand
if I was saved combine all of these into
a single diagram combine these into a
scene so off on the psyche if you want
to put this we're gonna do
multiplication in a second but before we
do that let's finish this off what would
it look like if I put these are regional
vectors if I place them at the origin so
if I put P and Q starting at the same
spot
we've already established what people's
cube looks like that we've established
what P minus Q looks like what are they
in relation to this well just add a few
more lines on this just to complete the
picture okay
remember the vectors direction of
magnitude but just as we demonstrated
over here you can move it any way you
like it can start and finish where if
you like they'll still go the same
direction still go the same distance
okay so I'm just going to put in an
extra couple of copies of P and Q on
this diagram from fleas from M symbols
from last week I'm gonna add in another
copy of Q over here but that's still
cute same direction same magnitude and
then I'm going to put another copy of B
okay can you see P plus Q and P minus Q
in this diagram yet can you see them in
every P is P plus Q
do you see it it's running across there
it's one of the diagonals right where's
P - Q where is it it's the other day
isn't it that one please look at the
direction really matters look at where I
put the arrow ahead on this interval
it's over here going off to the left
okay because you can see it's like yeah
look it's doing this and then heading up
there look if I track back in reverse
right
that's like negative cube do you see
that Q supposed to go down into the
right that's what it's supposed to do
but negative Q means that go the other
way and that's what sends you up and to
the left
okay so people's Q P minus Q they are
the opposite diagonals of a
parallelogram okay